[Musique]
emmanuel macron dit
sur les réseaux sociaux cette vidéo
intitulée nous retrouver rappelant les
différentes étapes du déconfinement qui
commence aujourd'hui
jamais je n'aurais cru voir une bande
annonce pour la vie normale s'amuse cet
internaute
cela ressemble à un trailer pour la
liberté ajoute un autre
une liberté bientôt retrouver à une
condition écrite à la toute fin et en
petit sauf situation sanitaire
départemental dégradé d'ailleurs combien
de milliers d'euros dépensés pour ce
film de propagande demande un internaute
tout ce cinéma pour paraître sympa et
grappiller quelques voix c'est
pathétique de sept internautes en colère
élève en bac pro transport toi alors est
melvin temps grève de la faim je suis
j'ai commencé une grève de la faim
depuis ce matin devant mon lit ça va
pour l'instant juste pour la santé
c'était était bien ce qui est très
important aujourd'hui c'est pas qu'ils
marchent dans la rue ce qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est de voir tant
de françaises et de français marcher
ensemble dans la rue pour le même motif
c'est à dire que nous voulons tous
retrouvé nos libertés nous voulons tous
retrouvés l'égalité dans ce pays et nous
nous opposons à cette dictature puisque
la france aujourd'hui pour moi je le dis
haut et fort c'est pas votre chaîne qui
le dit c'est consisté à l'âne pour moi
nous avons sombré dans la dictature les
gens messia qui n'a pas parlé alors ça
il est quand même vers 16 mai qui
devrait nous dire que tout cela est
grande émission de discipline je pense
que vous devriez de dire que tout cela
est de la faute de l'immigration pas du
tout bon non je disais je dirais
simplement que vrai
je suis heureux on est autant surtout
qu'on n'en pense pas moins et ça non
mais vraiment gonflé quand même p guerre
flatulences prout les fêtes sauvages
comme celle ci se multiplient samedi
après midi à paris d'autres jeunes
improvisent une rave party dans le parc
de bercy évacué très rapidement par les
forces de l'ordre
certains ne comprennent pas pourquoi
leur fête est interrompue
comment lui cela te faire la fête et
sont violents il utilise des arbres n'a
pas d'armes
c'est interdit et monsieur tout le monde
est interdite tous les jours et on dit
non non on dit non on ne se remet pas le
paquet au présence de jean michel
blanquer
jean michel blanquer ridor aujourd'hui
la vérité des marraines à moi attendez
j'ai juste impolis sert à rien mais
justin tu l'as fait je lui dis mais la
d3
vous avez dit gâtés cdu csu et bébé si
ces contrôles continus pour une seule
raison c'est parce que si vous acceptez
contre deux années vous admettez que
blanc caire avait créé sa maison elle
est mythique la vérité yann accord et ça
c'est énorme et quand vous voulez on
parle politique
apparemment vous êtes un expert juste
toutes ces civilisations qui est en
train de s'inventer est une civilisation
qui va mettre la passion et l'amour au
premier rang
jacques jacques louis mais c'est long
mais jean jacques bravo non mais moi vu
la passion et la mort personne n'y croit
mais bravo quand même sur trois
en
m
[Musique]
sont accompagnés
dans cet imaginaire
vous dites que vous ne voulez plus
d'hommes dans votre vie sauf quand vous
publiez en souriant une photo de vous le
lendemain matin en robe de soirée
parce que la veille au soir il n'y avait
pas d'homme pour le des zips et c'était
le seul moment je me suis dit ça serait
utile ça peut être pratique d'avoir un
homme pour enlever ma robe
aujourd'hui un homme il faut quelque
chose qui me plaisent qu'il respecte une
femme qui sait très bien comment la
satisfaire sur tous les plans
il faut qu'ils me serve à quelque chose
regin jolie culbute en selle des ventes
on va travailler le but
alors si vous aimez les culbutes si
caroline a des sentiments pour alexandre
elle sait ce qu'elle veut et n'a pas de
temps à perdre
elle a donc prévu un contrat de vie
commune dans le cas où cette première
rencontre se passerait bien
si alexandre veut aller plus loin avec
elle il devra signer ce mystérieux
documents sur le champ et se plier à
toutes les demandes qu'il contient sinon
ce sera fini pour le meilleur et pour le
pire
j'espère qu'un jour mon prince dit
[Musique]
penser
on s'est rencontré sur la toile montrent
maman n'a pas bougé d'un poil
sans transition j'ai envie de vous
parler d'endives
pour terminer sur la valeur l'endive
inscrite au patrimoine culturel de la
belgique depuis la fin de la semaine
dernière une annonce au goût amer de
l'autre côté de la rivière fossepel
question enfin j'ai jamais vraiment
analyser une poule de fond en comble
donc je me dis mais les pouces a quand
même des dons ça peut me mordre je me
dis il n' as tu vas t'occuper des poules
c'est à tes risques et périls bouffonne
romain on est dans la zone des 3 points
bouffonne et la bonne réponse est venue
c'est pas une intelligence plus que les
autres contrairement à ce que l'on croit
c'est lé chemin pour arriver à
comprendre quelque chose qui sont
différents donc des fois sur deux il
peut paraître très stupide idiots et des
fois d'un seul coup on va le trouver
intelligent fait partie de ceux-là vous
m'en parlez après son sourire diabolique
devant une maison en feu incendiés à
l'occasion d'un entraînement de pompiers
américains en a fait l'une des images
les plus célèbres du web les plus
lucratives également zoé la disaster
girl de la photo comme on l'appelle a
aujourd'hui 21 ans elle vient de vendre
sa photo 410 mille euros sous forme de
nft un certificat numérique
d'authenticité